today on the matt walsh show as more
school boards across the country adopt
radical pro-transgender policies it's
time that i think we take a step back
and trace the roots of this madness we
know that our country has gone insane
and that the insanity is being
especially forced upon our children but
how did we end up this way where did it
begin who did it begin with today we'll
discuss the two men who started it all
also doctors in florida walk out of the
job and protest against patients who
aren't vaccinated and the government has
investigated itself and decided that it
it didn't do anything wrong when ashley
babbitt was shot in the capitol though
they still won't tell us who shot her so
that's sounds perfectly fine and a viral
trend has people suffering devastating
head injuries while trying to climb milk
crates it is very hilarious i mean
troubling finally in our daily
cancellation we'll discuss the
revolutionary new social movement called
lying flat in which people just
lie around all day doing nothing all of
that and more today on the matt wall
show
this month following a summer full of
argument and contention over the issue
the loudoun county school board in
virginia voted to adopt one of the
widest reaching
and most permissive transgender policies
in the nation upon this decree from the
seven perverts on the board over the
protests of the two normal rational
peoples a seven to two vote uh males
will now be allowed in the female
bathrooms and on to female sports teams
and vice versa but the policy goes even
further than that as teachers and
faculty will be mandated to refer to
students by their preferred pronouns now
given that the preferred pronoun of a
gender confused child can change on a
daily if not hourly basis these days
teachers will have to spend i guess an
exorbitant amount of time keeping up
with their students every evolving sense
of self or face
unspecified consequences though we can
easily imagine what the consequences
will be as we need only look to the
example of loudoun county physical
education teacher tanner cross who was
suspended after stating at a school
board meeting
that he will not call students by
pronouns that don't align with their
biological sex so he he merely announced
his intention
to use proper pronouns and for that he
was suspended now a judge eventually
ruled
that cross had had to be reinstated
because the school violated his first
amendment rights and of course it did
but the district is appealing the
decision because nobody who recognizes
and respects biological reality is
welcome in their schools they have
declared even the gym teachers have to
toe the line
of course loudoun county is far from the
first and and even farther from the last
school district to codify this insanity
into their handbooks nearly all schools
public and private are caught up in this
cultural tide and they have the media
helping them along indeed the cnn
article about the loudoun county
decision
contains the sort of paragraph that
we're accustomed to reading these days
but would have seemed bewildering and
shocking had it appeared in a mainstream
news article even just eight or nine
years ago
cnn reports this let me read from the
article it says advocates have called
biological sex quote unquote an
over-simplistic and misleading term that
refers to the sex as listed on students
original birth certificates while sex is
a category that refers broadly to
physiology a person's gender is an
innate sense of identity the factors
that go into determining the sex listed
on a person's birth certificate may
include anatomy genetics and hormones
and there is broad natural variation in
each of these categories
oh biology is misleading they say
we are already past the days when only
gender was considered fluid biological
sex now finds itself on the spectrum as
well
this is the message as we know not only
from the news media and the state and
school systems
but from the shows and films our
children watch at the youngest ages
every week it seems another formerly
beloved children's program decides to
repackage itself as an agent of sexual
indoctrination the latest in line is the
kids musical group the wiggles
now originally this group is from
australia but it has fans all over the
world including my own children
though that will change now they are no
longer fans of the wiggles and will
never watch another wiggle thing ever
again
uh the wiggles have been around for
decades and mostly produced a bunch of
silly and frankly kind of annoying songs
about fruit salad and various marine
creatures and so on
but this week the wiggles unveiled a
youtube show called fruit salad tv with
a newly expanded cast of what they say
are diverse and inclusive characters
one of the additions is a non-binary
unicorn who uses they them pronouns
here's the wiggles pirate captain
feathersword introducing the genderfluid
character to the kids there's one last
friend that loves to be
around the ss feather sword now here
they come
right now
it's surely showing their unicorn and
shirley shawn has their own boat
whoa
ahoy there captain
scratches
that's what shirley shawn likes to say
scrumptious
scrumptious all right
has their own boat
you can tell how unnatural it feels for
this guy i mean the guy dressed up in
the pirate suit as well he looks like
he's in the 60s or something
and uh but he's going along with it
you could always tell with these people
when they when they it feels wrong to
them but they're doing it anyway
uh and they did clarify the wiggles did
clarify that uh this was not captain
feathersword having a stroke and you
know using the wrong words no he he used
it there intentionally they them because
this is a non-binary unicorn they were
they were they clarified that very
clearly
now
i think we make two critical mistakes
when we see how this agenda has
infiltrated every area of society
especially those areas that children
happen to occupy
the first is in thinking that we've
reached the bottom and it can't possibly
get worse
it can and it will
the second isn't thinking
that all of this madness began a few
years ago with roots that trace no
further back than perhaps sometime
during the obama administration or
something
both of these assumptions are wildly
wrong
in fact we need to understand that the
left sexual agenda is not making its way
down to kids now as a matter of
happenstance or because we've suddenly
reached that point on the slippery slope
on the contrary
this agenda was designed
from the very beginning
to prey upon corrupt and destroy
children this is all by design
kids have always been the targets
it's not a conspiracy theory it is the
truth and i'll prove it
what we're witnessing now in schools and
in children's entertainment is the
culmination
or maybe i should say continuation
of a plan that was hatched decades ago
it was always supposed to go this way
kids have been in the crosshairs from
day one
the sexualization of children is not a
logical extension of this agenda it's
one of its central points and purposes
nearly everything the left says about
gender and sexuality today nearly
everything that's taught in schools
implanted into young minds by non-binary
children characters and so forth
can be traced back specifically to two
men about 70 or 80 years ago
now of course no bad ideas can really
have a definitive
start date or birth place the person who
comes up with the idea was always
influenced by someone before them and
that person by someone before them and
on and on and on back to the garden of
eden
i say that all this began with two men
but i mean you could go back to the 19th
century with sigmund freud or his
successor wilhelm reich uh there are a
number of men
and they are almost all men by the way
who could lay claim to the title of
father godfather grandfather maybe grand
uncle of the sexual revolution
still i think it's indisputable
that we would not be where we are today
without the contributions of alfred
kinsey and john money now you've heard
me talk about john money before
he was the just a review he was the
psychologist who first invented concepts
like gender identity and gender role
those terms didn't exist the concepts
didn't exist before him he also coined
the term sexual orientation
money was the first or among the first
to identify gender as a human category
distinct from sex
that didn't exist before the era of john
money there was only sex and then gender
was a linguistic term it was words had
gender
the idea that people have a gender was a
new thing
that he helped to pioneer
he believed that your
self-identification as either a man or
woman was determined by society these
were artificial constructs by his
telling if it sounds like the modern
left has taken money's ideas and just
turned them into religious gospel
unchanged one which may not be
questioned or criticized that's because
that's exactly what they did
almost everything they take as
self-evident about gender was theorized
by one single guy named john money
problem is that he never proved any of
this
though he did try
when a little boy named bruce reimer
suffered a botched circumcision
effectively destroying his penis john
money recommended that his parents raise
him as a girl because why not gender is
a social construct
the parents went along with the plan and
all the while they brought bruce and his
twin brother brian to money's office for
regular uh sessions
and during these sessions john money
forced the boys to simulate sex acts on
each other
he had them take off their clothes for
genital inspections quote unquote as he
called them
he photographed the boys naked
and money called this childhood sexual
rehearsal play
money was unsurprisingly an apologist
for pedophilia and had stated that a
loving quote-unquote sexual relationship
between a man and a boy should not be
considered immoral you know that's
perfectly legitimate he said
now long story short and you know the
longer version if you've ever talked
about it before
the female identity did not take hold
for bruce he eventually figured out the
truth he reverted back to being a boy
which is what he always was and both he
and his brother lived damaged and
traumatized lives and unfortunately
brief lives until his brother brian
committed suicide by intentional
overdose and bruce a couple years later
went to a grocery store parking lot with
a sawed-off shotgun and shot himself in
the head
now you may think it can't get worse
than that story and perhaps you're right
but alfred kinsey gives it a run for his
money
kinsey had died and gone to hell about
10 years before money began his sexual
experiments on bruce and brian reimer
but he paved the way not only for money
but for the sexual revolution and for
nearly everything your kids are taught
in sex ed in school today
and nobody denies that by the way nobody
denies or debates his influence it is
undeniable
though they prefer not to discuss his
life or his work in any great detail
because the details are downright
ghastly
kinsey was originally a zoologist
i specialized in some kind of wasp i
believe
he took an interest in studying human
sexuality primarily as we know now
in order to justify his own degenerate
lifestyle he was and this wasn't known
until decades after he died
he was a sadomasochistic freak who
enjoyed among other things and i'm sorry
to tell you this
shoving toothbrush his bristle end first
into his urethra while strangling his
genitals with a rope
now sorry for the graphic details but
it's actually important context for
understanding the man and his work
and you live in a world that was largely
made by this guy so you should know
something about him
he released a book called sexual
behavior in the human mail in 1948 it
was a sensation at the time
almost single-handedly reshaped the way
western society views sexuality
through his research um as detailed in
the book
kinsey purported to show that sexuality
is is fluid
that things like homosexuality and
bisexuality are extremely widespread
he even said that bestiality is
relatively common he claimed that nearly
20 percent of boys who grow up on farms
have sex with animals
he said that nearly 10
of all men
everywhere have sex with animals or have
at least at one point in their life
he also claimed that nearly half of
adult men
um have had at least some kind of sexual
contact with another man at some point
what he didn't mention or tried to
downplay is that he arrived at these
conclusions by interviewing mostly a
bunch of prisoners male prostitutes and
sex offenders
and from this sample of prisoners sex
offenders and male prostitutes he drew
sweeping conclusions about the sexual
behavior of all men everywhere
and society adopted those conclusions as
fact and you will still hear them
repeated as fact you will still today
if you would ever sit in on a on a sex
ed class you will hear statistics from
that book
repeated today
and that's far from the worst of it
kinsey was very interested in showing
that children are sexual from birth he
was very interested in this
uh there's a graph in his report and he
also had he was there was this sexual
behavior in the human male and then
later he came up with a sexual behavior
in the human female and together these
books are known as the kinsey report
in the kinsey report
there is something called table 34 and
you should remember table 34
because it documents as he puts it you
can look this up online
as he posted it documents examples of
multiple orgasms in pre-adolescent males
he then lists children as young as five
months old yes five months old newborns
and he claims that these babies
and toddlers and young children had
multiple orgasms over the course of
several minutes or hours
he claims for example that an 11 month
old child had 14 orgasms in 38 minutes
now where did he get this data
how does he know this and why are the
times so specific i mean 38 minutes
well he interviewed pedophiles who
sexually tortured young children and
timed the abuse with stopwatches and
took notes
now kinsey claims that he didn't put
them up to this that uh you know they
decided to use a stopwatch and take
notes on their own i guess
that's obviously a lie
even if it isn't
the fact that he dispassionately and
even approvingly documented the rape of
children never reported any of the
abusers to the police
and published his findings in an effort
to prove that children are sexual and
therefore sex between adults and
children is not unnatural or immoral
you know that fact alone
is enough to condemn this whole thing to
the dustbin
this is the man who again your child's
sex education program is based around
this is a man who sent sex offenders to
rape children with stopwatch to time it
with stopwatches and take notes
and then he would sit down with these
monstrous child rapists and record
everything they told him
and then send them back to those babies
to abuse them some more
his his research institute the kinsey
institute is still operational and still
receives tax money to this day
most importantly his ideas live on in
the mines and from the mouths of
leftists and positions of power and in
all areas of life especially in schools
and media and hollywood all across the
country
this stuff is not targeting our children
by accident the men who invented this
sexual movement always intended this
it was their goal from the beginning to
sexualize children to tear down every
law and every moral code which shields
children from predations of adults like
themselves
these were mad scientists pedophiles
monsters quacks
this is the culture
and the world that they established
in which the modern left continues to
build
and which we must therefore
destroy
now let's get to our five headlines
if you guys know one thing about me you
know that i care deeply about vpns i've
got long a lot of really strong opinions
about vpns and that's why i can tell you
expressvpn is the best vpn there is how
did you choose which internet service
provider to use the sad thing is most of
us have very little choice because isps
operate like monopolies in the regions
they serve they use this monopoly power
to take advantage of customers uh data
cap streaming throttles the list goes on
but worst of all many isps log your
internet activity and sell that data to
other big tech companies or advertisers
to prevent icp isps from
from seeing my internet activity i
protect all of my devices with
expressvpn so what is expressvpn well
it's a simple app for your computer or
smartphone that encrypts all network
data and tunnels it through a secure vpn
server so that your isp cannot see any
of your activity and that gives you the
privacy that you deserve and have a
right to that's the reason i recommend
expressvpn is the best way to hide your
online activity from your isp just
download the app tap one button and
you're good to go so stop handing over
your personal data to isps and other
tech giants who mine your activity and
sell off your information protect
yourself with the vpn i trust to keep my
private uh my activity online private
visit expressvpn dot com slash wall
street's e-x-b-r-e-s-s-vpn
dot com walsh to get three extra months
for free go to expressvpn.com walsh
right now to learn more
all right you know i'm pretty uh upset
about this this woman
allegra kirkland
sister of i suppose sister of benadryl
kirkland
she's an editor for teen vogue and she
tweeted something out she said um i'm
looking for more people who can write
sharp timely op-eds on us politics for
teen vogue especially as midterms start
rates start at 250
and then she gives her emails so she's
looking for people to you know submit
and so i responded saying that um i'll
write i'll do it for free i'll write you
some articles for free you don't have to
pay me in truth i would pay you
i'll pay you a thousand dollars to let
me publish in teen
vogue and that's how badly i want this
opportunity and i really do
and then shortly after i tweeted that
response to her saying i'll do it for
free she deleted her her original tweet
she took down the help wanted ad because
i responded to it so i guess that is
that's my response that's her way of
saying no thanks or maybe
i'm i'm so good i'm so fit for the job
that she said we don't even need any
more submissions he's our guy
um i guess i i have that effect on uh
potential employers sometimes i suppose
all right now let's we'll start with
this doctors are now walking out of
their jobs because of unvaccinated
people here's a report from msnbc this
is in south florida
where doctors are walking out in
protests because of all these dirty
unclean
unclean unvaccinated people let's watch
this
just moments ago more than 75 doctors
staged a walkout to protest the number
of coveted patients coming to the
hospitals who have not been vaccinated
the thing hey let's bring in carrie
sanders because carrie you're in palm
beach gardens florida at this doctor's
walkout
carry with and i know the area very well
what americans don't understand is for
every unvaccinated person that's filling
up an icu bed that means with a
hospital's jam somebody with a heart
attack and i've known somebody in this
position goes there has trouble getting
in can't get treatment can't get a bed
it is a nightmare for the doctors it is
a nightmare for the nurses and to the
doctor's point of view
it's worse yet for sick people that want
help from them
that is truly reflective of the
frustration that you see behind me and
these doctors have gathered some coming
off their shifts to come out here
gathering to try to tell people please
first of all ignore the nonsense and the
absurdities that you're hearing people
say at public meetings and recognize the
value of what a vaccine will do
ignore the nonsense they say as they
walk out in a political protest while on
the job
they're worried about nonsense you see
them all you can see them all in the
background they're
heroically stoically standing there
refusing to do their jobs
uh at least for the time whether while
they're standing out there in this in
this stunt and we're seeing this from
we've talked about it already last week
we're seeing this from doctors more and
more uh there was the doctor in
i think it was alabama who uh put a sign
on his door saying i'm not seeing any
unvaccinated patients
uh then you know every day when you go
on social media you see more doctors
there was this doctor tweeted out uh
natalia salenkova who is a medical
doctor she said nearly 100 vaccinated
medical residents are taking care of
nearly 100 unvaccinated covet patients
does it seem fair it's not fair
and so this is what we're getting from a
lot of doctors it's not fair we don't
want to do it we don't want to take care
of these patients
let me
say a couple of things here first of all
uh and i i'm gonna try to put this in as
gentle a way as i possibly can
as is my way to be gentle
stop whining
you damned babies
stop whining and do your job
is it fair do we have to it's not fair
yeah it's fair you're a doctor they're
sick
that's what you signed up to do is what
you're getting paid to do you're paid
handsomely all those people standing in
the background in that msnbc report
they're all paid very well
dr natalia
is paid very well
very handsomely uh uh compensated for
their job which is fine i think doctors
should be paid well
i i'm if if i'm
you know when i was lying down for my
achilles surgery a couple of years ago i
was happy to know that the guy who was
performing the surgery and who would be
you know cutting open my body while i'm
asleep i was happy to know that he's a
he's a well-paid professional
but part of getting paid to do a job is
that you do your job
stop asking everyone to pity you for it
stop asking us to feel sorry for you if
you don't want to do the job then quit
quit and do something else
if you really don't want to do it
it's not fair
yeah we're in the middle of a pandemic
as we're constantly told
then so there's a lot of sick people out
there and you got to take care of them
i i i could feel sympathy for you if you
weren't begging for it so much
i can easily feel sympathy for people
who are not but the thing is when you
start demanding sympathy and begging for
it that's when the sympathy evaporates
at least for me i can't feel sorry for
you anymore when you're telling me to
feel sorry for you
just as i can't admire you when you're
demanding that we admire you
i can admire the medical professionals
who go in and do their job and don't
complain and don't record tick-tock
videos whining about it or dancing um
or you know aren't constantly begging
for attention but go in
and do their job perform their duties
and go home without making a big show of
it i can admire them
absolutely i do admire them
so how about that for an idea stop
whining and do your damn jobs
for god's sake
also
there there are so many examples there
there if we're going to take this logic
and extend it
it's not hard to see where this goes
as many people have pointed out
including myself
you know what about obesity
their obesity is one of the number one
killers in america
right now and uh and
at any point and and also
that includes a lot of people who've
died of covid
obesity kills a lot of uh many people
many thousands of people on its own and
it's also killed thousands of it
contributed to the deaths of thousands
of coveted patients
because we know that morbid obesity
is one of the major red flags
if you come down with covalent you're
morbidly obese you're in a high risk
situation
so
despite what we're told by the body
positive movement
you don't become obese by accident
you're not born morbidly obese
in the vast majority of cases if there's
no mystery you become morbidly obese
because you're eating a lot of junk and
you're eating way too much and you're
not getting exercise
and so are we gonna say if you have
chosen to live that kind of lifestyle
you don't deserve medical treatment
think about what think about what obese
people are doing to everyone's health
insurance premiums
how many even outside of covert how many
hospital beds are being taken up
by people suffering the medical
consequences of their own poor lifestyle
decisions
should we refuse
treatment to them
now the way around this what you'll hear
from people on the other side of this
issue
is they'll say well it's totally
different because obesity is not a
communicable disease
so it's not analogous
it's different yeah i know it's
different but that's why it's an analogy
okay in order in order to make an
analogy two things have to be different
if they're exactly the same
then there can be no analogy
this is a confusion i think stems back
by the way for the phrase uh you know
what that's apples and oranges you can't
compare that no apples and oranges you
absolutely can compare they're they're
very similar but they're different
in fact in principle you can't compare
an apple to an apple because it's
exactly the same thing it's like you
can't compare the number four to the
number four anyway
um yes it so obesity and covet
are different things
but there are comparisons you can make
it's not a compute communicable disease
but it is still a choice that someone
makes to be that way
and um it's it it's a
and that has consequences that that they
suffer and that society must suffer
and many
hundreds of hours
are spent by medical professionals over
the course of their careers dealing with
obese people who again are suffering the
consequences of their own decisions
so why should we refuse treatment to
them
but if you're hung up on the
communicable disease aspect of it then
okay how about this let's put obese
people to the side
what about
a so-called sex worker otherwise known
as a prostitute we call them sex workers
now a so-called sex worker who has an
std or or someone a porn star
somebody who's
someone on only fans at least until they
get rid of the porn in a couple
weeks uh what about someone like that
the porn star or or prostitute a
quote-unquote sex worker
has
stds should we refuse medical treatment
to them
an std is a communicable disease
stds have killed
millions of people
and they cause untold
death and destruction and misery and
suffering all across the world
and
these the people have gotten stds by
their own lifestyle decisions
by their own choices
so why don't we refuse treatment to them
that is an almost exactly analogous
situation
someone who has a communicable disease
that was brought on by their own
lifestyle decisions
but something tells me that if a doctor
were to stand up and say you know what
i'm not going to i'm not going to treat
any more sex workers because i'm tired
i'm tired of these sex workers coming in
here when they got the herpes and
chlamydia and they have hiv and all
these things
and they've got it because they've
chosen to live this way and to have sex
with 15 people different people every
day and i'm not going to treat them
anymore i don't want to deal with this
something tells me that all the people
applauding these these doctors right now
who are walking out of the job every
single one of them without exception
would be condemning that doctor and
saying how dare you this is your job
treat these poor these poor prostitutes
something tells me i think i'm right
about that
all right next this is from the daily
wire it says the capitol police officer
who shot protester ashley babbitt was
found to be acting lawfully
and in line with department policy and
will not face internal sanctions the
capitol police said on monday the daily
wire reported friday that the officer
who shot babbitt as she entered the
capital speaker's lobby through a broken
window
was formal formally exonerated after the
capitol police conducted an internal
investigation according to an internal
document
the internal capital police
investigation represented the latest
such open investigation into the
circumstances surrounding the 35 year
old trump supporter's death
a memo on the matter obtained by nbc
news said that no further action will be
taken in this manner meaning that the
officer who will not be named will not
face discipline
uh the capitol police unveiled the
report itself on monday officials said
they had interviewed multiple witnesses
and reviewed video and radio calls as
part of the months-long probe
so
radio calls that we haven't heard
uh video we've seen a couple of videos
that were taken by
people in the crowd
cell phone video
i'm going to assume that the capitol
police
looked at security video the security
cameras all over the place in that
building we haven't seen those
we haven't even been told the name of
the person who did this
and they say now as they said all along
that they're not going to tell us the
name they're not going to release the
name because of uh because of threats
and i could respect that
and i would be fine with that
if not for the fact
that every single time there's a
shooting that blm is upset about we find
out the police officer's name right away
and it doesn't matter if there's threats
i mean you can have some of the most
prominent famous visible people in the
country lebron james
uh making threats
and doxing the officer putting his
putting his uh
his image out there
and still they're gonna give us all the
information
that is demanded about that officer
just like they did in that case in the
makai brian shooting
so if this was a general policy of we're
not going to release the officer's name
unless they're charged with a crime but
if they're not charged with a crime
we're not going to release their name
because of concerns for the safety of
their family and also it's not fair to
them because if it turns out that the
shooting was justified it's not fair
that now that their name is out there
and they got to live in fear for the
rest of their lives
because of this
um i could respect that
if that was the policy but it's not
because again in every other case at
least if blm is upset we find out the
officer's name
this is the only case that i can think
of in recent memory
where there was a police shooting that
was uh controversial
and they didn't tell us the name
and it just so happens it's the one
shooting that blm
is not only unconcerned with and doesn't
care about but they're actually happy
about it they're cheering it on
they're happy that this woman died
because she's white and uh and they
don't agree with her politics
and as we've known along blm
couldn't possibly give less of a damn
about about police shootings it's not
that's never been what this is about
so that doesn't work
um
but we're supposed to i guess move on
now
because the capitol police
without showing us any of the video
without giving us any of the information
that they have
without letting us us hear from the
witnesses that they supposedly talk to
and without even telling us the name of
this person
they have looked into it and they said
we didn't the capitol police have
decided the capitol police didn't do
anything wrong
well that's it then i guess i mean if
the capitol police
if the capital police say they didn't do
anything wrong then i guess they didn't
do anything wrong
and again all of these
all of the people who who normally
hate the police
to say that they distrust the police
would be a massive understatement
i mean they believe that that police
officers are by and large racist serial
killers and yet in this case they say
well if the police say it was fine then
it was probably fine
it's an absolute joke
and at the very least this man's name
should be should be released and i you
know
it's it's the capitol police aren't the
only ones who know this guy's name
i can guarantee you every single
republican in congress knows who the guy
is they all know
and they could tell us but they don't
donald trump
was president when this happened
he absolutely knows who did it
in fact he said it he said he has said
that he knows who did it
he's not telling us
so i don't just put the blame on
democrats and uh and the capitol police
it's the same story again with
republicans
going along with the flow being
spineless gutless
jellyfish
when they could come out and say no this
is wrong
here you know there should at least be
some transparency with this
here's the man who did this
they could even probably arrange to leak
the security footage if they wanted to
that is what democrats would do
need it even be said you reversed the
situation here
and this was it was a capital police
officer who shot a a an unarmed blm
activist female
you know because she was crawling
through a window
and
she was shot and killed by capital
police
they don't tell us the name they're not
transparent about it
you can guarantee the democrat party
they would have that name out there they
would have the footage out there they
would have all the information in the
public immediately
instead we have republicans that just
sit on their hands and say well there's
nothing we could do i guess that's it
let's move on
all right see if you can follow along
with this uh report from the new york
post
it says
some kind-hearted strangers melted the
internet's heart after contributing 4
500 to a waiter who allegedly was
stiffed by homophobic customers at a
restaurant in madison wisconsin
um
now now
we will show you the
the receipt the note
so it was a bill for 142.95
and then the person this alleged
customer left 142.95 cents and then left
a note they said service was good but we
don't tip sinful homosexuals and sinful
is misspelled
now we have seen
this exact story with almost no changes
at all
um
dozens of times we have seen this
through the years recent years
someone doesn't leave a tip and they
leave a nasty note either it's a note
uh
you know it's a
it's an anti-gay or or sometimes it's a
racist note usually it's an anti-gay
thing this this tends to be this is a
genre where most of the entries are are
purportedly anti-gay
and
i don't think it's an exaggeration to
say that in every single one of those
cases it's a hoax
every single one has there been yet
a legitimate case of someone leaving a
nasty note on a receipt and it was real
um we're supposed to believe that this
is different now this is this is a real
one
there are already a number of problems
that i think jump out at you
starting with the fact that this is this
is a genre that is almost always fiction
so that's why immediately there's reason
to suspect
there are other problems too like for
example
um
this is someone who feels that strongly
about it we're supposed to believe i
guess this is a you know a bible banging
christian
we don't tip sinful homosexuals they
don't know how to spell sinful though
that's kind of a little bit of a red
flag
and also they took the time to note that
the service was good
so they they hate this waiter because of
their homosexuality but they loved the
service and they made sure to note to
put that down in the note you know the
service was great it was wonderful but
we don't tip you sinful homosexuals
so that's a problem and also how did
they know that the waiter was a
quote-unquote sinful homosexual
does does he introduce himself that way
i've never had a waiter do that i've
never been sitting at applebee's and the
waiter comes up and says uh hey i'm
chuck i'll tell you about the specials
today by the way i am a homosexual okay
here are the specials i've never had
that
so a lot of problems a lot of red flags
and also just the fact that you know
those of us who
run in circles with conservative
christians we just know that nobody is
doing this
nobody
even if you had someone who was inclined
to leave a note like that that wouldn't
it wouldn't sound like that that would
not be the note that sounds like a note
written by someone who is trying to
sound like what they think a
conservative christian sounds like
but this gets even weirder okay so that
was the note going back to the new york
post article it says
uh this is a face this was this was put
up on facebook by a guy named eric
salsweedle
and he wrote on facebook to the folks
who felt it was necessary to write this
hateful note and not tip don't worry me
and about 50 250 other others will cover
the tip for you so
he um
do we have the facebook post from no we
don't okay so this guy eric salzweedle
he runs some sort of non-profit
and this is in madison wisconsin he's
the not he's a he runs a nonprofit group
called do good wisconsin
and
he originally
he wasn't he was not the waiter
but he got his hands
on this receipt from someone who doesn't
say who it was from someone some some
poor waiter some poor homosexual waiter
gave him the receipt he eric salzweedle
posted it to his own facebook page
and solicited donations to himself
he put his own personal paypal and venmo
up and said hey everybody uh someone
left this note for uh you know a waiter
i'm not gonna tell you who the waiter is
and i'm not gonna tell you who left a
note doesn't matter uh but it's a
terrible thing why don't you give me
money and then i'm gonna go to the
restaurant and leave a massive tip with
your money to that uh poor waiter and
people did it
people sent him 4 500 and then he did a
follow-up facebook post later saying
claiming that he went to the restaurant
and gave the 4 500
to the to the waiter and he never told
us who it was anyway i tracked this um
eric salzwedel guy down on twitter
and um
i asked him i said i said hey do you
have any
when you were soliciting donations to
your personal paypal account
based on this receipt
and we don't know who any of these
people are
do you have any proof that any of this
is real that it's not a hoax
like how do we know that you're not
perpetrating a hoax or maybe the waiter
perpetrator hoax against you i mean how
do we know
i went back and forth with the guy on
twitter a few times and you could go on
my on my twitter page and see the back
and forth he the the long and short
answer is that he is not going to be
providing any evidence that any of this
is real he said i'm not making this up
he said he's not going to provide
evidence that it's real because i
wouldn't believe it anyway even if he
did
okay so you
you look
i'm i'm naturally a skeptic i admit it
uh
you decide for yourself whether this
sounds legitimate to you eric salzweedle
took a receipt
said i don't know i'm not going to tell
you who this is from or he did tell me
it was a friend of a friend so
his friend has a friend and then he got
the receipt from them but he's not going
to tell the person's name doesn't matter
it doesn't matter who left it none of
that matters
just give him uh five thousand dollars
and he'll and he'll make it all right
and and hundreds of people actually said
that that sounds totally legitimate to
me
even though this story is has been a
hoax 100 of the time in the past
and this is actually the least credible
sounding one we've heard yet
i'm gonna give this guy my money
my god
but you know what if you're that stupid
you deserve to be scammed
it's pretty clear to me you got scammed
that's my theory i don't know for a fact
i think
and uh you absolutely deserve it in that
case
all right before we get to reading the
youtube comments uh i got i have this
from today it's very important story
probably the most important story that
we have today this is from today.com
they say there's a dangerous new trend
going viral on social media it's called
the milk crate challenge and it first
popped up on tiktok and is now making
the rounds to social platforms like
twitter and instagram
experts warm the unsafe trend coupled
with the overcrowding of u.s emergency
rooms due to cover 19 could be a
disaster waiting to happen
um the milk crate challenge calls for
stacking milk crates in the shape of a
pyramid and successfully walking up one
side and down the other
um
sean anthony an orthopedic surgeon said
the milk crate challenge is very
dangerous we're seeing many orthopedic
injuries as a result injuries can
include broken wrists shoulder
dislocations acl and meniscus tears as
well as life-threatening conditions like
spinal cord injuries uh so the doctors
are speaking out they're saying this is
very dangerous but uh this is the this
is the trend it's it's very bad it's not
funny i don't approve of it at all
but let's just for educational purposes
we're going to watch one of these and
let's see this guy trying the mill this
is what the milk is again just for
educational reasons can we play this
totally i want you to be educated on the
milk crate challenge i want you to know
what it looks like so that you know if
you're if your children
if your children are stacking milk
crates you know it's probably pretty
good oh and that oh my gosh
oh you'll land it right on his back that
is a spinal cord injury it's not funny
at all though um and uh i don't approve
of it i'm quite concerned but let's just
watch one more
again
purely for the sake of uh of education
so if you see your children doing this
then that is a big big red flag
you see that you see the milk crate
pyramid in your yard and your and your
your kids say oh we're just you know
we're making a pretty design no no no no
there oh no oh my gosh
oh man
is that guy dead okay he's not dead
it is it's only
it's just
it's simply terrible it's not funny
there's not don't plea please everyone
do not try that
i kind of want to try it i do but i
won't
i want to try if for no other reason
then how funny it would be for me to be
going to the emergency room
you know with 15 broken bones and i got
to call my wife and explain what
happened
hey babe i'm going to the emergency room
uh
i don't have time to get into details i
was climbing some milk crates i broke 15
bones
anyway there it is so really really
concerning stuff
let's move now to reading the youtube
comments this is from
uh john who says it's funny that matt
looks like a lumber sexual portland
democrat with a plaid shirt and beard
while being a conservative i also don't
look the way people perceive me
more power bro
i absolutely reject the idea that plaid
shirts and beards are now a left-wing
signifier i reject that i detest it
can we stop with this since when is it
a plaid shirt is the most basic
that's not white that summer that's
really white dad fall but it's white dad
any time of year really
that's the most basic uniform for a
middle-aged dad and the beard
now you're trying to tell me that it's
some sort of a hipster left-wing thing i
i don't agree with that at all
forrest says uh it's not as simple as oh
just stay home then not everyone can
that's not an option for a lot of people
i started the show yesterday saying if
you're still
i i think it's pretty good advice and
it's a it's a it's a good compromise if
you're still deathly afraid of covid
uh that you don't even want to be out in
public if not if everyone isn't wearing
masks then the best thing you could do
is just stay home you can stay home as
long as you want
if you got to go to work go to work in a
gas mask or something put on rubber
gloves
otherwise stay in your house
let the rest of us live our lives
a number of commenters including forrest
here says that's uh that's not an option
it's that's not a good enough solution
well again i said if you're deathly
afraid of covet
and are not willing to live normally in
spite of it and alongside it
then you can stay home
and if you have to leave your home for
whatever reason
then you could take extreme measures
i'm sure you could find a gas mask on
amazon
the point is you need to do literally
everything you possibly can to protect
yourself and then
so you can stop worrying about us
because most of the worrying
you do about other people is based on
the fact that you also want to basically
live a normal life you see that's the
problem
what i'm saying is you need to decide
live a normal life and deal with the
reality of covid
or hide from the reality
so much of the strife and the anger
comes from people who they want to have
it both ways
they want to be paranoid about covid
and they want to feel like they're 100
protected from it but they still want to
leave their homes and live normally
and they want all of us to facilitate
that for them
right it's like melissa joan hart going
to disney world
she wants to be able to go to disney
world
and so everybody else there they have to
dress appropriately and do everything
she wants them to do so that she can go
to disney world it doesn't work that way
it's like i told you about back in in
the winter i went to uh
the the the relatively few times that i
was yelled at by someone for not wearing
a mask uh i went to uh my family and i
went to a christmas lights display out
outside at a botanical garden in
indianapolis
and we were walking along and there was
we weren't wearing masks and there was a
woman who was wearing a mask and she was
there too and she kind of yelled at us
for for uh
for not having masks on
but my point was what are you you're at
a botanical garden at a christmas light
display if you're that worried about it
then what are you doing here
if you think you might die
if you encounter someone else outside of
the botanical garden at the christmas
light display who's not wearing a mask
then maybe you shouldn't come in the
first place
see this is something that you do we're
all here because we're not that worried
about it that's why we're here
if i thought i was risking my life i
wouldn't be at a christmas light display
that's why i'm here because i don't
think i am
if you think that you are if you think
that it's risking your life and it's a
big concern then just stay home
don't go
leave the rest of us alone
and finally god's country says matt
you're a national treasure if you
wouldn't mind could you possibly ban me
from the show
well i'm not a circus clown performing
tricks for you okay i'm not a dog
barking on command
i'm not gonna tell you that you're
banned from the show just because you
demand that i ban you from the show and
for that you're banned from the show
very important news bulletin here if you
have not submitted your sweet baby gang
anthem yet then now is your last chance
to do it i know we do these reads a lot
when we say it's your last chance to get
this deal and then it turns out that
we're going to tell you about the deal
for the next seven 17 months but this is
different because actually there really
is a hard deadline here submissions end
tomorrow august 25th at midnight uh
because shortly after we get all the
submissions we're going to have our
american idol style
competition where we look at all these
different anthems and songs that were
submitted and we decide along with your
help
which is going to be the official sweet
baby gang anthem so it's very important
and there's a great amount of
responsibility that lies on your
shoulders here and i hope you take it
very seriously go to dailywire.com
sbg to
submit your sweet baby gang anthem and
if you're looking for an alternative to
the legacy media that actually values
the truth the daily wire readers pass is
perfect for you just as for just four
dollars a month you'll unlock exclusive
access to editorial content that you're
not going to get anywhere else so if
you're tired of the same old stuff you
get from the mainstream media
um and you know all of their columns and
editorials and everything it's always
the same thing over and over again and
you can't trust anything you read that's
why you got to try the reader's pass
from dailywire.com and again it's a only
four dollars a month even better we
sweeten the pot you can get a free
four-week trial when you sign up at
dailywire.com subscribe right now so
four dollars a month but you start with
a entire month for free go to
dailywire.com subscribe right now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
i have to confess that i had other plans
for this daily cancellation today but
those plans were hijacked when my
producer sean sent me this editorial the
new york times from a woman named
cassidy rosenblum everything from the
title to the writer herself to the
article all scream for cancellation i am
taken up by the forces of the universe
and moved in this direction practically
against my will i have no choice but to
cancel as some great philosopher once
said i'm sure
cassie rosenblum is a an an unemployed
former npr producer who left her job and
moved into her parents house
now that she's sitting at her parents
house more specifically lying down at
her parents house she's decided that as
she says in the title
of the article um work is a false idol
the piece is about her epiphany that
it's better more beautiful more pure
more true to do nothing at all just
lounge around all day
she says that this is a growing trend as
more and more people are deciding to
model their lives after fungus growing
on a dead tree and sit around all day
achieving nothing contributing nothing
of value to society this is what she
writes she says quote
in china this april a 31 year old former
factory worker named luo
uh
drew the curtains and crawled into bed
then he posted a picture of himself
there to the chinese website badu along
with a message lying flat is justice
lying flat is my sophistic movement mr
lao wrote tipping his hat to diogenes
the cynic a greek philosopher who said
to have lived inside a barrel to
criticize the excesses of athenian
society of athenian aristocrats on
chinese social media mr lowe's manifesto
and his assertion that he has a right to
choose a slow lifestyle of reading
exercising and doing odd jobs to get by
quickly went viral
sympathizer shared versions of a belief
that it is gaining global resonance work
has become intolerable rest is
resistance
so we see that um that the chinese
dude's version of lying flat includes
doing odd jobs and getting by
while devoting more time to reading and
exercising
this may not be a recipe for
professional success and if you have a
family then you may not have the luxury
to make reading and exercise into a
major overriding priority in your
day-to-day life but if you don't have
those obligations and you're still
working to get by
then who can complain can complain i
certainly don't
if you if that's how you want to live
then go ahead and live that way
fantastic
the problem is that our friend cassidy
like many of her american counterparts
are removing a key aspect of this lying
flat formula
she continues
it's not just chinese millennials who
are figuring out that work is a false
idol
i should know because i'm lying flat too
holed up in my parents house in west
virginia earlier this year i quit my job
producing an npr program in boston and i
haven't been able to stomach rejuv
rejoining the cacophony of the 24-hour
news cycle i'm far from the only one a
recent tweet that proclaimed i do not
want to have a career racked up four
hundred thousand likes instead
proclaimed the tweeter holla back girl
i want to sit on the porch
here in the hills the new silence of my
days deepened by the solitude of the
pandemic has allowed me to observe the
state of our planet in the year 2021 and
it looks to be on fire as our oligarchs
take to space
from the view down here on the carpet i
see a system that even if it bounces
back to normal i have no interest in
rejoining a system that is beginning to
come undone
now cassidy then gives other examples of
people who have made the heroic choice
to be lazy good for nothings and there
are many examples to choose from around
here nowadays that's for sure and then
she closes on a poetic note
she says quote in her poem the summer
day mary oliver asks tell me what is
your plan
well tell me what is your plan to do
with your one wild and precious life
my reply for now is simple
sit on the porch it's not half bad
for what is the porch if not a place to
chat with neighbors to marvel at the
hummingbird at the feeder to listen to
the wind in the chimes an altar for
cynics and alter for the erotic and
altar for the future
okay let me say first of all
please do not make your porch into an
altar for the erotic
especially not your parents porch you
weirdo
i can't imagine visiting my parents at
their house and saying hey mom i'm just
going to go step out on the erotic altar
out there for a second i mean the porch
sorry just don't look out the window for
the next few minutes please
but this is a technicality i suppose and
more a question of etiquette than
anything else as for the rest of this
tedious fart sniffing screed we need
only ask how cassidy has a porch to sit
on
or do whatever unspeakable thing she
plans to do on it in the first place and
i assume she's not starving while she
listens to the wind chimes and watches
the hummingbirds
i would also assume that most of her
lying flat is done in beds and on
couches and other pieces of furniture
that someone has to purchase
she is able to be sedentary she is able
to lie flat dreaming of ways to make her
slothfulness sound poetic in new york
times op-eds all because someone else
namely her parents in this case have
done the work and are doing the work
that she refuses to do
see that's the thing that these leeches
always leave out when they're promoting
this kind of lifestyle to the masses
they leave out the part
where not everyone can live like this
some of us have to work to keep this
whole ship floating
i mean what happens if everybody lies
flat
what if everyone retreats to the porch
what if we all decide to listen to the
wind chimes all day
well then nothing is produced
nothing is made
nothing is paid for
no food is grown or killed no crops are
cultivated no homes are built no roads
are paved there's no clothing no cars no
blankets no sidewalks no planes nobody
to fly the planes anyway no phones
nothing at all
not even clean water to drink
everything that you use or consume or
depend upon for survival requires work
to produce everything
there are no exceptions
even the things that are done by robots
well the robots have to be made by
someone
if nobody works everybody dies
if only some people work then the people
who don't work will die or else
they'll make the working people into
their slaves and cassidy on the porch
with the hummingbirds is really
advocating the latter option she wants
to do nothing and have you or her
parents or whoever she doesn't care
become her slave
this kind of stuff is either advocacy
for suicide or slavery it can't be
anything else
and usually it's slavery
why can't it be anything else i mean why
can't we just be in a world where nobody
has to work and everyone can lay on the
porch
well because
reality is hard
and cold and often cruel
we are born into a world
that will hand nothing to us
we have many needs
and many more desires
increasing number of desires every
single day
and the world will not satisfy any of
them for us
you have to work
or someone has to work to make that
happen in order to survive
you must impose yourself you must
extract what you want and need from the
world you must in many ways battle
against nature against the world just so
that you can live in it
now we don't think of it in those terms
anymore because we're so comfortable but
we're comfortable precisely because of
the work done by others by our forebears
our ancestors knew that every day was a
struggle a battle
and work was an intrinsic part of life
because they confronted that reality on
a daily and hourly basis we're fortunate
enough to live behind certain shields
which allow us to ignore that reality
but it is still a reality
and those shields require work to
maintain they're like a dam holding back
a great river and the river is named
reality
an unimaginable amount of sweat and
blood went into building that dam and
even more goes into maintaining it
we just hope somebody else will do it
and for now there is someone else to do
it at least in cassidy's case
but eventually
as more and more people are convinced
that apathy and laziness are not only
appealing but virtuous
and more and more people decide to lie
flat
we may actually run out of people to
repair the dam and fill the cracks
we may not have enough workers to do the
work
and then the dam breaks
and the cold icy waters of reality rush
in
and all the cassidies of the world drown
in it
and then she will certainly be uh lying
flat
in more ways than one
and also she will be at that point as
she is right now
certainly canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audios mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nico geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
joe biden hints that kamala harris could
be president soon
the former cia chief advocates shipping
conservatives to afghanistan and doctors
in florida refuse to treat unvaccinated
patients check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]